- It's not just dick and
poo jokes, no no no no no.
It's a deep critique of the way we are.
(upbeat country music)
- Hey, this is Kanye West.
Hello my name is Kanye West.
I love to share my opinions
and I'm really quite a nice guy.
Hello, my name is Taylor
Swift and I like to
socialize with other
skinny ladies like myself.
Contrary to my name, I
am not a garment maker.
Hello, my name is Hillary Clintons
and I don't have much personality
but you should vote for me because
I am not an assholes.
Okay this is Donald Trump.
Hello, my name's Donald Trump.
I really don't like Muslims,
likes those guys are so hot.
I just don't want them
in the country because
I'm gonna want to stroke some more
and I've got like a really big fancy
(speaking foreign language)
and I've also got an enormous
Hello, my name is Oprah Winfrey.
I think it's very very very nice
to have my Book Club.
I like to collect my money
and I'm a billionairess.
I don't need to share it, it's all mine!
(laughing)
Hello, me name is Jerry Seinfeld,
top o' di marnin' to you.
Who are these people?
This is Leonardo DiCaprio.
My name is Leonardo DiCaprio
and I am so relieved that
I finally won the Oscar.
Surely I should have got the big statuette
before this time, it is not fair
but I'm glad anyway, and
who would have thought
that my movie, The Revenant,
would have done so well.
I did.
Wait a minute, that's the wrong voice.
That's King Julian, alright.